In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 11 on which we commemorate our venerable
Father Elias, the cave dweller, the memory of our venerable Father Elias, the cave dweller,
and of his spiritual Father Arsenius.
And Elias was born at Regio in Calabria in about the year 861 of a rich and noble family.
One day in church, a monk appeared and reproached him for being luxuriously dressed and for
trifling his life away, whereupon the young man took it upon himself to live aesthetically
and to afflict his flesh.
When he was eighteen, he left his native place to escape marriage and made his way to
Tarmina with a friend.
The austere conduct of Elias was too much for the friend who soon left him, only to be killed
by seracines as he went his way.
Elias took ship for Rome, where he wanted to venerate the tombs of the apostles.
He met a holy monk called Ignatius there, to whom he opened his soul and to advise
him to return home, in view of the immorality that affected the clergy and people alike
in the city.
Back in Regio, Elias heard of the renown of Saint Arsenius, who was leading the ascetic
life not far from the town.
Arsenius clothed him in the monastic habit and became for him the very archetype of all
the virtues.
Elias applied himself zealously to all sorts of manual work, despite a disability affecting
one of his hands.
The result of an accident in childhood and spent much of the night bowing to the earth
and raising hymns and prayers to God.
He used to say, he who works with his hands and prays in his heart becomes doubly rich,
because he serves Jesus present in the person of the poor like Martha, and he attends to
the sayings of the word of God with his intellect like Mary.
It happened that one of the influential priests of the city took possession of the best
of the fields belonging to the two ascetics and bribed the judge to refuse them justice.
To avoid dispute, the saints abandoned their monastery and settled in the church of Saint
of St. Eustratius near the village of Armon, where they devoted themselves to prayer for some
years.
They are from the cares of this world, but then it came to them by divine revelation that
the Arabs were about to invade that region, and so, like other holy monks there, they took
refuge in Greece.
For seven years they lived at Patras in a tower from which they drove out the devils that
had long terrified the inhabitants, becoming renowned as much for their ascetic feats as
for their miracles they worked.
Once the seressine danger was over, they decided to return to their home country, despite pressure
to stay in Patras, from the bishop, who, disappointed in this matter, falsely accused Elias of stealing
the sacred vessels.
The saint let them put him in prison without even trying to justify himself.
In the end, the bishop repented and let the two ascetics go back to Calabria.
Upon returning to their hermitage of Saint Eustratius, Arsenius and Elias entered into spiritual
friendship with the holy ascetics Daniel and Elias of Sicily, who had founded a monastery
not far away.
Elias of Sicily, who had the gift of prophecy for warned Arsenius to prepare for his departure
from this life, and he advised his companion Daniel to make the other Elias the head of their
community after he, Elias of Sicily, had died.
When the time came for Arsenius to die, he called Elias of Calabria to his side, gave him
some final words of instruction, and fell asleep in peace in the year 904.
Long after his death, the seressines rifled the church, and opening the tomb of Saint Arsenius
they found his body incorrupt.
They tried in vain to burn it, and finally replaced the holy relic in the tomb.
When Elias of Sicily died, Daniel, remembering his prophetic word, summoned Elias of Calabria,
who on arriving at the monastery found the door shut, for Daniel had decided to put him
to the test.
Elias waited at the door, without complaint, until the evening, when the brethren received
him with great joy as a true monk who had acquired a patient's able to bear every trial.
Elias had fasted throughout his journey, but when Daniel offered him food, he would take
none, saying he was unworthy of nourishment.
During the vigil, Daniel was overcome by sleep, but Elias roused him to watchfulness.
After some months, Elias, in search of a new spiritual father, went to dwell with the
Hermit Cosmos and his disciple Vitalis in their remote cave, until they moved on to avoid
visitors.
Elias remained to mount in the spirit alone, like a serif, all a flame with divine love.
One day he dreamt of a swarm of bees humming melodiously as they flew above his head.
He gathered them in a vessel, and put it in a wonderful garden full of bright flowers.
When he awoke, he realized this meant that henceforth God would have him welcome and
guide brethren in the way of the kingdom of heaven.
His disciples increased rapidly in number, and the cave became too small for them.
Then they discovered a huge cavern that they transformed into a monastery, with the church
dedicated to the Holy Apostles Peter and Paul.
The neighboring caves, as well, became veritable hives, inhabited by a great many monks, who,
in their living, followed the example of Saint Elias.
He taught them to be skillful in warding off the attacks of devils, and injuing as he did
the friendship of the Lord.
He was able to supply all their necessities.
One day, when the wine for the holy sacrifice chanced to be lost, the saint changed some
water into a most sweet smelling wine.
On another occasion he fearlessly scolded a bear that was destroying the monastery's
hives and vegetable plots, and the animal made off a shamed of itself.
Any time, in ways unseen, he protected his monks from whatever danger was threatening them.
He foretold their faults, and when they followed his councils, everything became possible
to them, and they were able to do works beyond the common measure.
Besides all this, Saint Elias exerted a great influence for good upon the way of life
of the people of the surrounding countryside, and delivered many who were possessed by evil
spirits.
Crowds of ill and destitute folk came to the monastery, attracted by his miracles, and
not one of them was turned away.
At times of frequent Arab raids, Saint Elias took refuge in the mountains, clad in the skin
of an animal.
He would spend up to forty days, scarcely eating or drinking anything.
On other occasions he would withdraw to the citadel, exhorting his disciples and the inhabitants
to repent of the faults that had brought such adversities upon them.
In his old age, the saint ate almost nothing at all, and the most part of his drink was the
flood of tears that flowed ceaselessly from his eyes.
On feast days, though, he would spend the night in the most joyful singing of hymns and
canticles.
After foretelling his coming departure throughout the preceding year, he went to venerate the
tomb of Saint Elias of Sicily, and on his return he transferred a large number of novices.
Then he withdrew to his cave and bore in silence a violent stomach ache for twenty-five
days.
At the end of this contest, he gave up his soul to God in the presence of the bishop and
a large number of laypeople on the eleventh of September, in the year 960.
He was 96 years old and was buried in his cave.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.